reporting with the zoom to be able to
use what we lost yeah we're not
recording it wait so none of this got
captured
killing it guys
killing it why don't I see the zoom on
here
[Music]
wait so does this mean like that there's
people maybe on YouTube right now just
watching us in silence
let me turn on the uh
this is OBS we're usually get some audio
yes oh boy
let's take our audio interface
it combines three and four for some
reason which I hate here let me fix it
by pressing down on it yeah it doesn't
work
when you release it doesn't work
huh
interesting
okay
so what do you think about
um
are you recording now yeah do we have
audio yep all right so what do you think
about Nancy Pelosi's husband getting
assaulted what happened I didn't see it
he was in his home and some guy came
into the home and he was like
Hey where's Nancy Pelosi and then he hit
him with a hammer
I mean that happened at my house too but
a different guy I think well I think
that begs the question like how did the
husband respond like if he was like
she's in the backyard
she's swimming in a pool of gold coins
right now yeah like Scrooge McDuck I'm
saying like if that's right over there I
hit her too go at her yeah exactly if
the husband gave her up like why'd you
hit him
she was apparently in Washington DC
yeah imagine him being like oh dude
she's out of town he's like God damn it
you get one shot at the Pelosi house and
you get the husband
the most useless Pelosi yeah yeah yeah
oh man
uh I was on just so you know I was on
DJ's uh or I was on why is your
Instagram handle DJ DJ DJ he's a serious
because you're not a DJ are you no I'm
just a human being
well the reason why I did that is
because I was posting on Reddit like
here's what I think about politics and
then I posted on Imgur to post on Reddit
and then on Imgur I didn't even know
that was like a thing but they have like
their own community and their own
comments so like I check my Imgur and
they're like why are you this is Hans
Kim comedy this isn't funny this is just
political and boring so I changed my
name to DJ Hans Kim so I could say
whatever I wanted so you have you put
sincere political takes on Reddit
I put some takes that I think are clever
on Reddit wow and then the irony though
is that he's like maybe if they think
I'm a DJ they'll take me seriously
well I'm just saying like you can say
anything on that like just because it
says just because it says Hans can
comedy doesn't mean that I'm going to be
doing comedy just like if I put DJ on
there doesn't mean I'm going to be
mixing tracks you should have put like
you know Bitcoin Hans Kim and then yeah
exactly or like you know what I'm saying
or like I don't know
something like that so they're not
they're like you're not actually trying
to be funny you're putting real
political opinions what are these
opinions can we read one of the opinions
that are like clever what are these
comments happening oh dude I hate I
can't I can't have these comments
because no I kind of love it I just
can't if anything about my appearance I
can't this guy literally wrote why don't
you have someone on that knows what
they're doing
[ __ ] yeah what is the point of a podcast
if it's professionally produced Ben
Harvey writes which one is Asian
I kind of dig these comments like I'm
glad that they're too far they're too
far away for me to read you could be the
moderator for what I get to see yeah
imagine but seriously imagine thinking
like like DJ gives you credibility yeah
exactly it was a joke it was the
ultimate joke it was a meta joke what
can you give me an example of one of
these sincere political takes what's
something you feel strongly about
um
the cops are a bad thing most of the
time okay
I I meant to say I did a pod with him
yesterday and like right out the gate
he's like so what do you think of
Ukraine
I know we'd be like what do you think
about one of our sitting political
officials getting attempted murder but
they just weren't there yeah so did his
the husband got hit with a hammer yeah
he's in the hospital he's in the
hospital he's he's like 900 years old
too right yeah that's got to be a pretty
rough prognosis if you get hit with a
hammer yeah 80. that's usually fatal in
your 80s yeah not even a screwdriver
have you ever seen an old boy yeah yes
that's what I was thinking of yeah the
hammer so you know what what he was in
Korean it's a Korean
and it has a hammer in it yeah is the
guy with a hammer it's a guy that gets
kidnapped and then he doesn't know why
and he has to figure out why he gets
kidnapped and released I watched a
dubbed version so there was like English
and it was like but I don't give a [ __ ]
about spoiling like a movie that's 50
years old but it's uh he like [ __ ] his
daughter or something right that was the
yeah well the thing is that he
accidentally revealed the to the school
that uh this guy was [ __ ] a sister
and so the guy got mad at him and he was
like I'm gonna make you [ __ ] your
daughter Jesus and so to get back at you
and they cut out his tongue is that part
of it too he cut out or he cut out his
own tongue this is a show of like don't
tell anyone please don't tell her I'll
cut out my tongue it's so Korean just
like torture yourself for no reason like
this is how serious we weren't gonna
tell dude it's fine yeah
it's just like needless sacrifice and
yeah but it's a very good movie in my
opinion I really like it what's it
called oh boy it's like a classic Korean
movie yeah they remade it with Josh
Brolin Korean films are kind of having
like a big Resurgence now right or
Resurgence or surgeons yeah it was an
early parasite like yeah it's also like
K-pop is a thing that we suddenly care
about in America like when I was a kid
nobody knew any K-Pop bands they were
huge in Korea yeah
it's like basically like in sync and
Backstreet Boys to like on steroids
right and like they sing in Korean right
yeah yeah isn't there a black pink isn't
they aren't they a big Korean group
right now yeah black pink black pink you
don't emphasize the black that much yeah
take it easy take it easy
for the record I said both in equal
I think there was some blacks the black
things yeah
I was like black pink
are you trying to look at the webcam I
don't know
these commenters are right you're
[ __ ] dumb I think you know you should
go poop right now that would help okay
what if that was like the best 10
minutes of your all's day you know oh
dude it was we really connected while
you were in a at 10 minutes I was
generous of you to think that only took
10 minutes okay we toured an entire
[ __ ] monument
look man when Nature Calls you do not
text it back
luckily that was a very small Monument
yeah
oh there's like other like the election
everyone always would recommend to me
that's another Korean movie
um
I'm resisting making a racist joke right
now the direction yes thank you for
making it for me
this erection
Insurrection okay so serious question
from the chats I think it's a Cody a CX
Daniel so I think of Cody Daniel he's
kind of doing what you're doing he's
putting an X in there instead of an a do
you think he's being exhibit instead of
an a he's a transgender he doesn't
identify as I think coxy no I'm trying
to look less fat what if he identifies
as a DJ
okay maybe not so anyway uh okay Nate
writes well first off Cody Daniels wins
who's going to win the World Series the
Astros or the Phillies I mean the
Phillies I hope I mean you would like to
thank the Astros what's your hot take on
this uh he's trying to be contrarian I
don't care no I loved yeah I love the
ass I'm sorry did I say Asher What the I
meant lilies are The Underdogs okay yeah
what were we talking about oh uh Korean
films and stuff yeah
yeah Koreans don't make good porn though
Japanese make good porn really why don't
Koreans make good porn they're just I
mean we're in one now I'm gonna be
honest this is not a great porn they're
just not confident enough to make good
porn
I think that might be you might be
projecting onto the Korean man
I was it's just like all Korean porns is
like the woman like berating the man
like that's it that's all you have oh my
God I guess I need to get that dub too
because I've never noticed anything
before have you watched Korean porn I've
watched a lot listen I'm a married man I
don't watch porn very much anymore but
in my day I like was at Peak horniness
when internet porn like remember that
[ __ ] that was like uh it was like you
could torrent porn yeah you can still do
that yeah but then when that started I
was at The Cutting Edge of Technology oh
yeah you were getting [ __ ] that no one
else was watching I love how you're
about to be like have I watched Korean
for a buddy I've watched oh dude yeah
except for the stuff that's illegal of
course of course listeners of course not
um yeah I mean I think Korean porn's
fine I like Japanese porn though they
really know how to make good porns do
you have this with things to conquer the
world because I can't watch uh black
dudes in porn because I need to be able
to see myself in the porn and that's the
only thing that's different is what
about Hispanics you can store whatever
like skin maybe that's related what
about lesbians the men the women can be
of every [ __ ] person wait so you need
you need to see a white porn star to
identify with them yes a male honest
thing a man so that's what I'm asking do
you like how close uh geographically do
they have to be to Career
well you think it's a g like I want to
see Asian people you're like I don't
really like Korean porn Japanese porn
which I don't think Japan is like that's
like tentacles I think right I think
also the Japanese porn made it into
American porn and I just watched
American porn yeah but
um no I don't have that kind of thing on
yeah I don't have that kind of necessity
I don't necessarily have to have Asians
[ __ ] I like girls getting [ __ ] by
black dudes too
I just like to see it how they how they
the reason I don't like that is because
it's also my nightmare so are you
serious there's always like the joke
about like oh uh the black black person
[ __ ] your wife yes I don't think
that's a joke always I think that's a
real thing wives and husbands
I love how like for you you're like it's
like you know how like kids need to see
like an Asian movie star in a Marvel
movie yeah are you in a porno you're
like I identify with this guy dude I
like I even will go so far as to say
sometimes watching like average dick
porn is great listen again ADP mostly
off porn in my in my life now I'm 36
years old through menopause but uh
but yeah dude like there was a time in
my life when I like
porn was like a medication you know what
I mean yeah how'd you get on it makes me
feel great uh I mean we know you got off
on it but like how'd you get off it I uh
got I've started dating my wife I
started having regular sex does she is
she adamant about porn usage she has no
uh we have no rules about porn usage we
have a donut don't sell policy which is
that I don't tell her and she doesn't
ask yeah because she's not watching porn
correct
these are mine that's that's great that
you organically just stopped watching
porn yeah it's mostly just like uh I'm
not trying to [ __ ] every Keyhole that I
come across you know Justin Brooke just
wrote who married this guy
let's make use of this tenure call it
good yeah
I love that that's awesome you put up
put a baby in her and now she's stuck I
know nice but she can't get rid of me
completely no matter what you're gonna
get like over here a little bit Yeah
okay all right fill in this this whole
how old is uh is your little one she's
uh three my daughter she's nice so you
know he's figuring about
10 14 years she'll be listening to this
and she'll Google her dad listen if my
daughter becomes
I'm [ __ ] disowning her
yeah what if she's like I don't like
Hans Kim but I like DJ Hans Kim
I like his remixes yeah not a big fan of
his comedy
would you ever do you want to get
married Hans
yeah definitely nice Hans is a Christian
conservative under it all I think I
could see it yeah it was even a strong
nuclear family yeah
um yeah I mean is it that weird to have
sincere political takes
um I think that uh it's weird when
comedians do it a lot of times because
they're usually ill-informed
and also uh they're not
that's not like what you go to for like
go to them for yeah but who is well
informed Tucker Max or Tucker Tucker Max
is I would take political takes from
Tucker Max has some good text yeah which
one's Tuckerman he's the I hope they
serve beer in hell guy yeah he had the
website oh yeah wasn't he didn't he
write some book about like womenizing
isn't that what I see the pickup artist
guy no no but he did right I hope this
before that is this a natural yeah
we just said scumbag right yeah yeah
yeah yeah well I didn't know that I
haven't read the book like what's the
premise of the book oh he gets drunk and
he has a good time and he's white yeah
that's basically it and it's you would
watch it as a as a young white man and
be like this is the life I want you know
that's like every Adam Sandler movie is
just like a like an aspiration for white
dudes interesting that's what I want to
live like Adam Sandler in a movie
um yeah I mean what do you think about
Kanye we talked about this yesterday so
I want to hear your take Casey my
president Kanye West yeah oh my
president your president it's tough to
keep admitting that I voted for him
um you voted for it no I did I did used
to say that when people would ask me
because it's funnier than saying Joe
Biden um
I uh
yeah I mean it's a pretty rough I think
he's going through some [ __ ] and uh
little down you know a little low this
guy Hassan says he's the most divorced
dad in America
he does a thing he's doing a thing right
now that comedians do where their whole
life is comedy so they start to think of
things exclusively in terms of Comedy so
he's like you know who I want to run the
world are like people who run sports
teams record labels and movie studios
and it's like well that's just because
that's the [ __ ] you know yeah and so you
think that like those are the smart
people because those are the smartest
people that you deal with you know right
it's like Kyrie Irvings think of the
World is Flat because the basketball
court is flat
laughs
uh yeah I mean that's going to your
point about not doing Politics as a
comedian I don't think Kanye should do
politics or race I think you should
Channel all this energy into music like
he's going on interviews being like
that's funny oh I came up with a little
joke if we marry again her name would be
Kim yay it's like this needs to be a
lyric and a song not a interview
response did you so I listened to the
whole
um Lex Friedman
why which so I actually thought I don't
I don't never listen to Lex Friedman
show before that I don't think but it
was like he like pushed back on him and
[ __ ] it was like an actually good
interview but um he
uh Kanye Jewish yeah Kanye said that he
uh went to an Anthony Jeselnik show yeah
I heard this like right before and he
was like using Anthony jeselnick as
inspiration for his intestines
it's like so funny to be like you're
like oh [ __ ] Kanye mentioned me that's
gonna be so cool except for that one
time yeah how funny would it be if he's
like the whole time he's like well this
whole everything I've been saying I'm
just trying to do Anthony jeselnick
it's gonna have a very dry punchline at
the end of this imagine how Jessica
would feel I mean I guess flattered but
yeah
I mean you really can't be held
responsible for how people take your
jokes like he was probably doing
ironically and Kanye is like oh yeah
that is true the Jews we were in the
media yeah
I did like did you guys listen to the
interview no okay so every time what did
you listen to it on it's a podcast maybe
like the Lex Friedman show or something
I don't know I don't know what it's
called exactly but the uh it's uh he
kept going like he's like well my
lawyer's Jewish my whatever's he's like
like this is evidence that all Jews do
this bad stuff yeah and it's like well
you got some bad dudes in your life it
sounds like but
I did enroll my daughter in his school
pre-enroll pre-enroll but uh yeah
Academy
hopefully it's not as bad as that album
well that's the other thing about him
too is like I do think he's a really
brilliant guy but also like I haven't
liked his music since late register no
uh the last one was uh College Dropout
late registration graduation graduation
is the last one that I like really loved
and the other ones I'm like okay we're
gonna keep pretending this guy's a
genius every time he puts out a [ __ ]
sound imagine sending your daughter to a
school by an artist who you know
literally made an album called College
Dropout
yeah what are we doing imagine what are
you talking about I got the paperwork in
already I've got my deposit down on a
seat at the school yeah
what do you think about Kanye aunts uh I
think he's like just trying to be the
opposite of whatever everyone else is
doing and yeah just doing the opposite
of what everyone else is doing is not
always the right answer
well yeah I think that's definitely I
think he's definitely fine with being a
contrarian and I think that this time he
like went too far and he's been too
adamant adamant about like the um
because he's like yeah he just won't
stop saying if he said all the things he
said but didn't be like it's the Jew's
fault I'd be like you're making great
points but it's like you're like it
keeps coming back to and all these
people are Jewish yeah
yeah I mean he definitely notices
there's a problem and the problem is
like money could use wealth inequality
right yes people that own Capital but he
doesn't know how to formulate it
properly and he's hanging out with
Candace Owens
yeah the one thing I will say is I think
he's got the same frustration that first
off again he's like deluded by his own
wealth and success but he
uh feels underserved by the Democratic
party and I know many folks that are
starting to feel that way but the answer
isn't to go to the Republican is to go
deeper to the left well maybe to the
people that are trying to go to the
right and then be like oh you're trying
to go to the right let me go way to the
right yeah I get what you're saying I
understand where you say that but I
don't know if that's like those folks
are helping it's like the like the
latinx [ __ ] is like nobody wants that
except for white ladies on the far left
you know what I mean but that's all just
a distraction the real problem is
economic no I agree completely right so
like uh like the Democrats are just like
serving the same Masters that the
Republicans are 100 agree with you so
what we need is economic reform and
everything else will take care of itself
I think like the trans thing is just
because we don't have enough money so
people are just playing around with
their genitals because they can't like
so I actually excavate I don't I think
that's actually like where there's
I think that that's not a symptom of
having not enough money I think places
where they become obsessed with gender
usually have a lot of money I think U.S
wealth has and like quality of life
leads to these like it's like there's
not like constant there's not like cases
of depression and who are these people
they're like college students that have
no job prospects they're like middle
class but they they can't really
influence the world that they live in
like they might be comfortable but they
have no agency yeah but again I think
that's because like I think when you
look at like sub-Saharan Africa they
have no there's like parts of that that
are like very desolate and those folks
don't have busy right exactly who worry
about their gender yeah yeah I think the
thing you're saying but I think the fact
that these people they still have like a
pretty good quality of life without a
job that's like a cause I'm terrified of
what the country but we can't just like
make people starve to death so that they
don't turn transgender no for sure I
don't think that's what I said
I'm agreeing with you I think the the
problem is absolutely the wealth Gap and
I think there's like class issues all
over the place and I think it benefits
both parties to make it racially divided
yeah because then they can run on that I
think it's like absolutely yeah I mean
we don't need politicians to tell us
what to do morally all we need is the
economic [ __ ] to get figured out and
until that does and but even that
they're not really incentivized for like
to get to your lady Pelosi your Dear
Nancy Pelosi that lady's become like
nearly a billionaire off of and I think
she's like worth like 130 million but
off of like
insider trading basically like she makes
210 Grand a year and is worth 130
million dollars or something like that
right why would that lady make things
better for the poor when she's like
benefiting from it right yeah but the
answers yeah right exactly like Dan
Crenshaw is pretty bad sure of course
West Virginian politicians right listen
I'm I'm like particularly triggered when
people make uh liberal uh politicians
out to be like these godsends because I
live in a blue area but if I lived in
Alabama I'd be making this point about
whoever's running Alabama I just happen
to live in a place where they people
like Dia like what deitis DFI there you
go thank you out of uh yeah I mean it's
not uh a useful system anymore red or
blue but I think the answer is probably
to go more towards Europe and Japan and
not towards West Virginia and Alabama
what do you mean like in terms of
politics like we should be closer I see
what you're saying the Hague and stuff
but they're all going right I mean I
don't know about Japan but well Japan
had that dude uh the dude that just got
assassinated was like their their Trump
and there's like a bunch of right-wing
populists by the America they were like
just keep yourselves from being
communist keep these fascists in charge
but yeah I mean they're slightly going
to the right like Italy and stuff for
sure like there's they still have health
care they still have a good social
safety yeah and that's something that we
need that we don't do here well that's a
thing that's interesting is people will
be like well there's conservatives in
Europe but like even the conservative
parties in Europe and Canada believe in
Universal Health Care like yeah that's
like a that's like decided over there
yeah are we part of is this a like a
dirt bag Left podcast is this the nuke I
want to do that I like Hometown Dirtbag
left I think so I don't know is there
they don't really talk about politics
too much I know I've never listened to
it Stavros has like uh socialism is gay
or something oh really
but uh yeah what do you think about uh
Casey's politics
I don't know I've been sitting here
listening it's like we talked about this
yesterday it's just sad that like I I
like I I said this yesterday so forgive
me if if anyone's listening twice it's
just so sad that like we take an 18 year
old we throw them at a state school they
take out a lot of loans they graduate
now they maybe owe fifty thousand
seventy thousand there's interest on top
of it then they need a job because they
also need some Health Care like you're
you're it's sort of like I don't I hate
like using a word
like it's not it's like I but it's like
some kind of indenture do you know like
you're beholden to slavery man I didn't
want to use a term because it's not you
know it's not it's not an equitable
phrase but it is like a modern day sort
of like like you're beholden to this
employer because of and they give you an
iPhone and here's the latest episode of
Rick and Morty and then you're like oh
I'm free so since this is a sincere
political points podcast that I wasn't
wasn't aware but I'm gonna make one now
yeah so you Hans you and I are both from
the Seattle area it's one of the places
in the world where there's like still
Native American tribes right yeah like
in the midwest but everybody got shipped
to Oklahoma but we still have so they'll
do land acknowledgments this is my my
problem is that Native Americans on
average have like
severely less wealth than white people
and Asian people and Hispanic people
black people and Native American Asians
in there because Asians are doing better
than white people is why well that was
like two percent of us there I'm in
Seattle yeah no Seattle's got a lot of
Seattle yeah it's uh where I grew up
like a minority or like a significant
minority there yeah for sure uh but
anyways my point is Native Americans are
doing very badly and financially and all
we do is land acknowledgments right we
do this [ __ ] thing but the problem I
have in the Northwest you do that [ __ ]
in Chicago fine but not to point out
your thing but where we live it's like
they're like there's actual Native
Americans yeah give like you're like
this is the the land that was
historically occupied by the Puyallup
Indians and you're like yeah go give it
to them they're like driving distance
from you oh you mean they're just doing
like placards or like acknowledgments
they'll do it like before a meeting
they'll go we want to acknowledge that
this Microsoft building occupies land
that was historically belonged to like
the duwamish tribe coin toss and be like
Jets get to kick off but yeah it's
[ __ ] nuts and it's like those people
are like in in the Midwest and the East
Coast Native Americans are like a fairy
tale like there's not very many of them
but where I'm from I grew up on a
reservation and you can give the land
back Microsoft if you want to actually
do something worthwhile instead of this
empty [ __ ] gesture at the beginning
of a meeting that like a zoom meeting
with 45 people on it isn't that better
than not doing land acknowledgments I do
the reason I don't think so is because I
think people stop caring once they've
done the land acknowledgment I don't
think it like but I think they stop it
at all you turn into a trump supporter
why because you're just like [ __ ] him
who gives a shot I don't think you say
[ __ ] him I think you [ __ ] do stuff
with like real like actionable like you
do real actionable things so that's like
the first step to getting there is like
sort of being like okay let's just give
them a little time out of our day
um but I think like uh like I see this a
lot with uh some like uh black comics
where they're like you can't like
be white and also be thinking
the the right things because then you're
rich and you feel good about yourselves
you only minorities should be able to
feel good about themselves and they like
[ __ ] on people that are like uh trying
to do the right thing for being like
having the right answers because then
they're like uh they then they have the
whiteness and like they're on the right
track in terms of morality they're like
no you don't get any of it but it's like
they should have some of it isn't that
like uh there is like I read an article
in New York Times recently there's like
uh there's like millionaires for
taxation there's billionaires for like
like I was reading some articles choose
for Jesus yes or it's like no I was
reading this Times article the other day
there's like a woman in Europe whose
parents like her family owned
pharmaceutical she's a set to inherit
billions and she's literally like I want
to give this money to the environment I
want to give this money isn't that just
a tax break
she's just trying to get it well yeah I
mean I I forget I'd have to pull up the
art but what do you mean that's a tax
break why would it be a text well if you
made a donation but I think her point
was she wants to be taxed on it but this
is this is kind of the insane thing in
America it's like people are not taxed
man I swear our taxes are very low
yesterday our taxes are very low that's
rich the rich are not taxed though is
what I'm saying of course yeah the
effective tax rate is like again
Washington state with sales tax the
effective tax rate of wealthy people is
like 15 and for poor people it's like 35
yeah it's [ __ ] up we agree economics
are the problem Hans we agree yeah so
what do you think about skank Fest I
didn't get in I'll tell you that much
I I couldn't apply the other years but
then this year I applied and got [ __ ]
did they make you pay to play no they
don't which is good yeah that's like the
most ethical Comedy Festival yeah even
though it's called skank Fest yeah
what's the uh why is it called skank
Fest remind me because of the legionist
gangs oh that's right that's right yeah
I think yeah it seems like a fun time I
wanted to go yeah did you go to the sun
this year yeah I went it was fun it was
like a blast it's a festival with all
like Comics there because usually you
never see Comics you're just passing
through the same cities right right well
it's all like I mean it's a lot of New
York Comics which are yeah better than
the others yeah every other city in the
world yeah L.A Comics are a little too
heavy on the uh personality they're like
look at me this is like a long setup
because at least you got to stare at me
I heard it I've never done comedy in La
I except maybe once like I've heard it's
a lot of like actors and actresses which
doing like their same five or something
like there's actors and people that are
comedians that want to do acting and
it's like I think the actors influence
the comedy there yeah they're a little
more performative yeah than normal
interesting have you done comedy out in
La yeah
for a while like two months wow was that
van life still yeah okay right before I
moved to Austin right before you killed
Gabby Patito you so this was like the
pandemic you just were on a road trip
and then you're like wait you were that
was before that that you went in the You
Started Van life way before it was a
hashtag not just not to [ __ ] blow you
on this but well I mean it depends I
mean the people were doing it forever
like ever since the Sprinter van came
out that really changed the game because
then you could stand up in it yeah yeah
and it was a good car to drive
um but yeah there were tons of videos I
watched videos and then I was like I
want to do this and then I moved into a
minivan and I've been doing it for four
I was doing it for four years like 2017
or something 2016. yeah and just not
paying rent waking up on a street in New
York
yeah were you at least paying then see
that's what I'm curious about what would
you pay to park for zero zero yeah in
Long Island City you could park on the
uh Street there was no street sweeping
or anything wow did you like have it so
your van like nobody could tell you were
in it when you were asleep yeah a little
bit you could tell if you were looking
that didn't mean that you had to drive
out to Long Island City every night did
it Long Island City is not as far as
that sounds it's a Queens basically yeah
Rhode Island City Is Right on the coast
between Manhattan yeah so what's that
drive it's not a drive at all it's I
could take the subway it's one subway
stop away from Manhattan so you would
leave the van parked in Long Island City
and just do Subway yeah
the thing wouldn't even drive my minivan
was a piece of [ __ ] I bought it for 700
bucks wow and the battery kept dying
they couldn't find the title it was this
shitty little mechanic shop in Coney
Island that yeah that's the second worst
thing they've done first thing is
yeah those hot dogs were not very good
yeah no Fort Wayne Coney Island
they said you know they said the thing
on the there's like a sign in there that
said we steam our buns yeah that was
like the worst part of it it was like a
mushy [ __ ] it was such a gross hot
dog it's a damp bun yeah and also it
just felt like the hot dog was just
putting like boiling water it didn't
feel like it was done over a grill or
anything sure the hot dog has no texture
but at least the bun is also mushy yeah
yeah
yeah that was a shitty it was like good
literally shitty yeah I know for one
[ __ ] inducing yes
um but yeah I mean it's good like uh
garbage food like if you're just like I
want to feel full yeah you can shove
that in your mouth I feel like that's a
place that should be open at like one in
the morning and but probably closes at
like 4 30 p.m yeah yeah like everything
else in Fort Wayne I liked it I was
about to say I like the Retro inside but
then I realized it's not retro because
it's just it's just that old you know
like retro is like you chose to like
design it in an old-fashioned yeah this
is like now it's been around it's not
retro it's antique yeah yeah have you
been to Katz's in New York yes yeah it
was like it kind of I mean cats is much
nicer but it reminded me of that like
that kind of vibe
that uh decade yeah the same decade one
did way better than the other
well it's still open though it smells
horrible
dude it was like I mean imagine if you
cooked hot dogs in a [ __ ] hallway for
1940s ventilation
you made a good point Chris that the
bathrooms like it would have been a
tight fit to go into the bathroom the
doors were wet for much better so the
bathrooms were like thin like like back
when people were thin also by the way I
made this joke on stage yesterday but
Fort Wayne is not a thin City last time
I came out here I ran out of two XL
shirts the second time
yeah guys imagine doing merch you're
like okay I'm going to La I'm gonna pack
some Smalls okay I'm going to Fort Wayne
double XL dude I did that this time I
literally ordered for this trip I was
like I know I'm gonna need more excels
and double XL
it's like it's like you bring different
merch for you know I mean dude I think I
think genuinely if you're going to like
a non-metropolitan Midwest City bring
some [ __ ] double XLS because you're
gonna need them yeah it's hilarious
they're heavy people
I'm not talking [ __ ] either I'm like the
same size as these people so you're a
petite yeah
uh yeah that bathroom was like it was
like thin it was like old timey you know
it's like old-timey yeah back when
people were like smaller now it's an
outhouse that they just built the wall
yeah it even said whites only on it
that's how old it was
this was a this is in the north this is
too far north barely now this is like
shares of Indiana shares a border with
Kentucky those Kentucky bourbon is made
in Indiana but also Indiana is not known
for its progressives
this is the new Confederacy Rebirth of
the clan was in I want to say Skokie no
but it was somewhere down in Brown
County Indiana I think Gary Indiana yeah
something like that home of the uh
Jackson Five I believe
and they did nothing wrong any of them
Muhammad Ali is from Louisville okay is
he yeah that's the Louisville Muhammad
Ali Airport
cool
so yeah see we're learning something
I think Will Rogers is from Oklahoma
City that's why the airport's named I
think he died flying the plane by the
way
and they named the airport
that's like Michael Jackson helicopter
the Amelia Earhart yeah
[Laughter]
bus station was that a bus that got him
the Leonard Skinner guy no they uh got
into a plane crash oh was it and that's
the one the guy lost an arm right I know
I'm thinking of uh what's that band no
Leonard Skinner legit lost band members
right yeah who am I thinking of where
the guy has uh the drummer has won
that's definitely I think he was born
with only one on gotcha he's still yeah
so that one arm might be like I don't
know who the best drummer in the world
is but I know that that dude's remaining
arm is the best drumming single arm in
the world there's no doubt about that or
the one-armed category
someone wrote it looks like you are next
to Red Band and Fat Tony
that's just Casey
why do they call you fat
I guess you're fat compared to Tony Tim
Tim Saboteur writes she ain't a lady if
she ain't 280. hell yeah
hell yeah my wife is very thin but oh
hell yeah that's body that's so funny
good for you man I know it's real
upsetting for her how's uh how did you
like that Park that you met us at the uh
Promenade Park Promenade Park yeah it
was fine were you guys like like finding
prostitutes or something theirs or
something they're just hanging out there
wasn't any it wasn't like it was just a
park it was like a normal city park
right yeah it was on a river yeah remind
me of that Park in Spokane Riverfront
Park in Spokane yeah yeah always
concrete yeah
that's a good thing
to have it's like just non-permeable
surfaces by the river
that's what they're that's what they
actually have in Chicago Long Lake
Michigan it doubles it's a park but it
doubles as a retaining wall so we have
the lake is [ __ ] insane and all that
erosion along Lake Michigan's a big deal
like they say that'll be our uh global
warming issues like the Lakes will rise
the city will flood uh all the Lakes
rise
just was can you just like cut a river
into them well so so that's actually the
interesting thing we have the Chicago
River now which has this uh gate system
at the lake and when we open it it'll
send water down the river but the
problem is when there's a gigantic storm
or flood or rain like if it rains for
too long the the river will rise and it
won't if it gets too high it won't allow
for runoff from the lake
and so that's you know the New York
Times wrote this God I sound like an
idiot the New York Times but like yeah
there's a reporting in Chicago yeah the
Chicago Times can uncover their own City
yeah so
but yeah it's it's kind of crazy it's
the the Great Lakes are no joke like I
was reading the other day about like
this is a SSS Edmond Center or something
like like this giant tanker went down in
Lake Superior just got swallowed up by a
by a road wave and just yeah it was a
real crazy it was a theory yeah I mean
it's so big that it's almost an ocean
but not really yeah great I would call
it great a great I'd call it one of the
greats a great lake or a shitty ocean
yeah
yeah I mean uh
I think uh like it's crazy like to be by
water that can just like if you have
like a you know like a water yeah like a
thing of water and you move around it's
gonna Splash it's it's insane how big
like Lake Michigan I think is 120 miles
wide
like it's it's a saying you can be uh
you know they say that there are times
that when you're in Detroit where you
can't see the Chicago skyline like maybe
you could because it is you know such a
tall Skyline but it's it's just crazy
big like what did you see the lake
instead of the Chicago skyline like you
couldn't see the sh like if you were in
Michigan you probably couldn't see the
Chicago skyline because it's 120 miles
gotcha gotcha and maybe with the right
lighting you could you know but like
it's just crazy like I was out on a boat
there a couple weeks ago and like we
were seven miles off the coast and I
just knew like if I had a fallen
overboard or whatever like I wouldn't
have been able to swim back in like
thank you for doing the hand motion that
was like very L.A comic of you
I'm working on my loose La 40. you know
so I was swimming
Church you guys [ __ ] with uh tsunamis
you know about tsunamis yeah the uh when
in like the pandemic when everyone was
depressed I knew did what everyone else
did is like Zillow places that you
couldn't afford yeah along the ocean
incredible and I uh
like dude the whole Oregon coast it's
like literally the value of a house is
like double if it's outside of the
tsunami Zone because they know that
shit's all just gonna get torn down by
water one day it's gonna be the new
Coast soon yeah we gotta invest early
for your children yeah
yeah I mean uh that's the best real
estate is right by the water I mean it's
still uh transporting things by boat is
the cheapest way to do it yeah
so being by water is beautiful it makes
us feel good and
I don't know we need water helps you
cool down
I don't know why we need water I mean
there's plenty of landlocked cities but
there's like most cities are built by
rivers or Ocean or something I like yeah
I take it for granted when people are
like they'll come to the West Coast and
like I need to see the ocean and I'm
like oh why like it's [ __ ] it's just
always been there you gotta cross the
peninsula yeah or well even like you can
get the salt water very easily but also
like having a mountain there when my
sister moved to Chicago and I was like
I'd come out there and it'd be like the
nose of the plane leaves the ground and
you're like I can see this whole [ __ ]
City like it's it's so flat and it like
I've been in the shadow of Memphis what
are you doing he's got a hair on him and
I just had to get it off it's a Pew
sorry a lot yeah yeah I just didn't want
to be put it to the webcam again you
[ __ ] suck dude you suck you [ __ ]
suck dude far away I don't know well I
just didn't want my hair to be on Hans
and then is that your hair no I was I
was hoping and then you call it like
yeah
is not gonna watch this again right I
hope to I'm gonna edit that part
this is the new Korean porn yeah yeah
all right you guys just want to make a
porno yes please
same camera
the lady in the elevator who is just
like frantically trying to notice things
oh dude that lady for sure she was she
said the she said a thing I'm so glad
you noticed that lady too because she
goes this wallpaper is beautiful yeah
but in 20 years you're just gonna have
to tear it off and I was like oh this
lady just yeah she said like that lady
just is I guarantee you that lady is
just horrifically depressed but is like
Stepford wiping her way through her 50s
and it's like is this everything that
life has to offer dude let me just try
to spread my misery everything comes
back and everything goes away and you're
like oh my God like jump off the roof
lady well I mean I think when we meet
strangers we want to tell them like our
deepest philosophy that we've been
working on yeah and that was her little
tidbit of wisdom is like don't put
things up because you're gonna have to
tear it down again don't enjoy anything
because at some point it might go what
yeah obviously she was broken up with or
something she's divorced that she was
there with her husband I think I think
she was doing that act in front of her
husband he has to live with that all the
time I think she was just like oh look a
shiny thing what about this well that
could be two which is also very annoying
but yeah I mean they were struggling
with the elevator true like and like get
it open they were not just struggling
like having they were like having an
emotional
problem when you showed up and fixed the
elevator problem yeah they didn't want
to admit that I helped them or that they
needed outside hell they were like we
were happy struggling I bet I guarantee
you they went to the room they're like
thank God that Chinese guy came and put
his card up to them yeah what would we
do without the Chinese
yeah they were I don't know it was a
it'd be great if instead of getting the
entire like Nation wrong like and it'd
be great if they were like thank God
that Arizona man came and helped us that
Mexican came in yeah
so thank God that's South African who's
pro-apartheid came and helped us I mean
necessarily just a ridiculous guess you
know yeah
I just feel like uh ever since the
pandemic people are a little more like
not as friendly or they're not willing
to be like hello neighbor how are you
today like that's like all gone really
do you really think so yeah I know it
why yeah just because we were supposed
to not talk to each other yeah so it
became a virtue yeah to not say hello
interesting and then like everyone
became divided it's like do you support
Biden or Trump and then it's like you
might be the enemy that's destroying the
country but don't you think some of it
is like in social media now it's very
fashionable to turn on your camera and
be like I'm recording you yeah what did
you say to me say it again yeah yeah I
think that's more that where like people
don't want yeah you're either gonna go
to a 10 which is like did you ask for
more milk
did you ask for cream but also some
people are like two I was supposed to
say black coffee you know at the Chicago
airport I was like black pink I was
wearing this Mariners hat right and this
guy is that you're like you're from
Seattle and I was like yeah kind of
close to there and he's like [ __ ]
Seattle and I'm like are you from
Seattle and he's like no I'm from Denver
and I'm like okay and he goes yeah [ __ ]
Denver too it's all it's all run by
[ __ ] and I'm like like dude I could
be the mayor's child you know like you
don't know like what the [ __ ] I have my
whole identity in Seattle but also
clearly that guy is like just [ __ ] any
everything like you could have just
[ __ ] Democrats he just hates Democrats
well that's also how you figure out the
thread that's also how he thinks that he
can relate to people like people will
like this if I do this yeah that's what
he wants he wants to commiserate with
someone who's like [ __ ] everything yeah
I hate everything too yeah yeah and I'm
just like you know they're both okay
cities
320 days of sunshine a year
close to Boulder Red Rocks love it yeah
actually if you could just do Denver in
Seattle half the year each you'd be in
good shape you know or what if that was
his personality he loved everything but
Denver yeah he's actually really
Sunshine of lollipops except for those
two topics oh Cleveland I love Cleveland
you know you got to go to court Wayne a
destination yeah yeah yeah yeah he's
like Coney dogs in Fort Wayne
the Old Fort yeah yeah he's like he's
like but Seattle [ __ ] Seattle yeah
the space space needle or whatever yes
that is what it is yeah that's the thing
about sports hats is like an invites
like really like people who are Fanatics
yeah this is great someone just wrote
Hans blink three times if you're being
held
okay he hasn't blinked and that's good
we're doing good hold four fingers up so
just just for a roll of three here you
go now you're doing it to the webcam yes
God you're so stupid again uh yeah I hit
this joke for a while about how I think
uh Sports replaced racism for people
because they're like now they don't hate
people for the color of their skin
they're like I hate you for the color of
your shirt yeah you know you're from
this city yeah dude I think you're
getting burned someone just oh I believe
it who wears Skechers these are these
are new balances what are you talking
about these are white supremacy shoes
right here okay they had a thing that
they were supposed to be white supremacy
or like the face of what's are you
wearing Skechers no these are Nikes okay
these are these are Nikes all right
these are the uh the most comfortable
shoe I've ever worn don't you dare
accuse me comfortable for several years
okay a warrant to put a section New
Balance theme here yeah
Aviator Nation no Aviator Nation are you
a big uh you're a pilot
no they did a comedy show there they
gave us 300 in uh free merchandise which
was like a shirt oh sweet wait you did a
counter show for Aviator nation and they
gave you merch they paid you with merch
they paid yeah
it's like a Abercrombie and Fitch but
before they got big it's like a boutique
gotcha wait is it I've never heard of
American English I think we're too old
for Aviator Nations yeah they're not
that big they're just sort of like uh
trying to get bigger like American Eagle
yeah
it's like so many companies vying for
Market Supremacy yeah that we don't know
about until they achieve it I did not
have Hans being like a secret economist
in my [ __ ] in my in my mind one I
mean I don't yes I'm not good at it see
this guy wrote I thought that was a
retro New Balance shirt and I'll be
honest all day I did too for some reason
I thought that was an n
you know oh yeah well it's really
examine why you're seeing things
everywhere
whoa whoa
[Laughter]
I'm terrified to get on there and see
what these comments I'm glad you're just
giving me a couple bad ones every now
and then instead of having to read them
the whole time how's the tattoo healing
it's great stop reading the comments I
think they're funny it's just so what's
the thing with the tattoo you got like a
you I got a tattoo I saw the pictures so
the guy this guy comes up and he's like
Hans Kim kiss my ex
and then there's a comment he's a tattoo
artist he's like I think that was his
first time on Scottish or something and
then he was like really would you get a
tattoo it's like do you remember kissing
this guy's ex I was like nope uh and
then uh he tattooed me I was like what
should I get and I got the kill Tony
knife oh nice okay eye the eye and kill
Tony is a knife so how long ago was that
uh it was like three weeks ago almost
dude how long does it take tattoos to
heal is that two weeks oh so you're good
it's fine yeah the answer is it's fine
it's fine I went through the hump
letters on the knife or is it just a
knife it's just a knife yeah nice that's
cool yeah that's actually like a cool
tattoo yeah it just sort of accentuates
my torso now there's something on it
right it's like uh like a little logo in
the corner of it two other tattoos no
that's my only one yeah I'm sure when
women see that they're like wow a knife
on his chest like you know it's yeah
that's good for that's fine I I don't
like many tattoos do you have tattoos no
I've known yeah I have none because I
there's nothing on passionate it's hard
to get a tattoo of stand-up comedy yeah
I used to have this joke about how I you
sort of it was about how I would have
gotten the Ninja Turtles and now they'd
be the middle age Mutant Ninja Turtles
and uh it's on YouTube by the way a few
folks are out there it's on my YouTube
but I put it out and then I put I
literally put it out on a Sunday morning
and people started like tweeting at me
like did you put this out because Essen
now did their middle-aged Mutant Ninja
Turtles thing last night and I was like
oh [ __ ] so now it's not even in my ex
anymore yeah yeah you copied it yeah
which is I mean I put it out like the
same day but it's a it's on YouTube if
you wanna yeah
yeah it's these monsters that are making
fun of me wanna go read my [ __ ] go
check out
um but yeah I mean uh the knife the
tattoo is fun
um yeah I mean you don't have it's hard
to get like because I know someone who
has a tattoo of a microphone and that
just looks like yeah I don't know it
doesn't really it kind of looks like a
dick after a while like it's a rough
tattoo yeah and who gives a [ __ ] about
microphones it's just like a tool it's
not yeah it's not like that symbolic of
Comedy it's also just like I don't know
anytime I've met someone with a tattoo
of a microphone they're usually gonna
quit you know or should have years ago
and are still doing it because they have
the tattoo who really wants to talk
loudly
yeah I can't imagine getting a comedy
tattoo outside of like that where it's
like this thing exists and it's made my
career bigger right as opposed to like
these this is like like if when people
get like the Laughing uh or the [ __ ]
those faces the like silhouette or
whatever those are called the masquerade
masks or whatever they're called uh the
tragedy and yeah like [ __ ] that you're a
pretentious [ __ ] don't yeah that's
art yeah my life is about the Arts this
body is for thespianism yeah right yeah
dude I'm like like that's kind of my
thing with uh that's why I was making
fun of you about your sincere your
secret life of sincere political things
on Reddit is like so much a comedy is
just like be funny and don't talk about
it you know like that we don't need the
[ __ ] serious uh the death of Comedy
right yeah not something you do make
your political takes you lived your life
however you'd like to but when people
are like I'm like when they're like this
is a Brotherhood we're going to war
together I'm like oh dude we're like the
opposite of one yeah
yeah exactly I I just love I still love
the idea of putting just DJ in front of
a name so then now you can do political
you should do it you should do it I
think imagine a tattoo though where like
you're like I don't want to explain it
you just put DJ hey is it pronounced
[ __ ] by the way so it's Italian yes
it's pronounced Hans I've been calling
you just a horrible yeah I've been
recording it I'm Gonna Cancel you one
day finally somebody needs to
yeah you say my day Rock no it's um yeah
it's there's apparently there's a town
in Italy called trani and there's uh
literally uh hundreds of us so I'm just
patronies yeah hundreds of [ __ ] do
you identify as a [ __ ] uh I do I do
what do people say when they see your
name and they have to read it uh the the
it's it's insane it's uh the the worst
people with my name to be the worst
people to be trusted with my name are
like Open Mic comedians or straight
white uh like hosts they can't wait to
say it they're like Chris you see how
excited I am
I've been able to say this in two years
yeah it's like I've waited my whole life
for this that's funny they're like black
pink
so yeah yeah people that want to say it
too much yeah so but it's um it's fun I
uh I do hate I did want to say on
tattoos I hate when like I had this uh
woman serving my friends at a table and
she had a quote on her arm I was like
wait what's the quote she's like and
it's like dude if you get a tattoo you
gotta begin yeah so you can't but you
are a little friendly to people I think
in a great way yeah I think you'd pull
it off because it seems natural you
don't seem like you're just doing it
yeah it seems like that's how you
interact with the world you called me
brother a lot last night when we were
drinking and I was like this guy really
thinks he's my brother well I also
thought we were going off to war
together
you did do a little bit of the thing
where you go dude this thing we do is so
crazy and I was like yeah I like it I
like it you get away with some [ __ ] I
would find annoying I look at you as a
fellow [ __ ] yeah we're both I said
tronnie and I'm looking at the camera
we're part of the community I wish I
went out now it's just like it's like
yeah we were out drinking and it's like
but no it's like I the funny thing was
like what's what I says to I said to
this uh person it says to the servant so
it says to this broad right and I I said
I was like what's the tattoo and it was
the um the Marilyn Monroe quote do you
know that one like if you can't handle
me at my worst then you definitely don't
deserve me that sounds like someone who
would be reluctant to tell you about
their time
my favorite is like do you know the
Marilyn Monroe quote like we knew like
she was best known for the [ __ ] she said
yeah you know what I mean I also really
hate that quote because you're basically
saying like you can't if you can't
handle me when I'm a huge total [ __ ]
yeah I'm gonna be a horrible person yeah
just deal with it yeah if you want my
[ __ ] yeah and then you get the five
percent of me that's kind you know yeah
you know what I'm saying like quote
tattoos are rough especially if you
quote someone that's living because it's
like they could become Kanye West
how many people have Kanye lyrics
tattooed on right now there's a comedian
that got a tattoo of trump 2012 2020.
when it was like a joke Nick de Paulo no
I think it's like Jason something in New
York I'm sorry I forgot your name but
now he's like an act he was he's like an
actual political figure and now he has
Trump 2020 honestly oh wow and it's
totally taken the wrong way Jason is a
political fight so so did the that's his
name did the comedian yeah did the
comedian get
yeah he's like a jokester he's like a
silly guy got you okay yeah he's like
yeah he's always making cracking jokes
imagine like you do you meet a woman you
go home with her you know you're having
sex and then all she looks over and
she's like Trump 2020. she's like get
out of me right now
what year did you get there he got into
like 2014. it turns out that tattoo uh
allows you to stay in you don't have to
get out of her at all yeah but just
imagine like being like like I can't you
know like I I don't think I could date
someone with a trump 2020 tattoo you
know I mean my wife got one on her lower
back but it was just a joke I guess it
rules that guy out
yeah oh yeah Trump said it was good it's
insane you know like yeah I mean we
elected a joke as a president and now
everyone who yeah who appreciated the
joke when it was actually funny right
and got a tattoo like they should have
like anybody best for it dude imagine
imagine like you know his experience
watching election night right it's Biden
versus Trump or no it's Hillary versus
2020 and like yeah it was 2016. 2016.
yeah it's Hillary versus Trump and but
and he's upset for all the wrong reasons
no no no no no oh my God and then he
just looks he's on the phone with a
tattoo artist yeah what was once a joke
is now a prophecy also he's like if he's
watching it in public it's got to be so
confusing for people to see this guy
with a trump 2016 tattoo I go no yeah
he's like I'm gonna get uh Bernie
tattooed on my arm next his body is like
uh yeah that newspaper that that guy
read to predict the future yeah just to
imagine like waking up in the morning
and be like oh boy yeah
dude and then I think like imagine in
the weeks because America those who did
not like Trump like it being in Chicago
like Chicago is obviously very
Democratic I mean that is a that's like
that's a liberal stronghold right like
that carries the state so imagine like
walking into the tattoo parlor in like
New York City in like in Brooklyn and
being like listen
I must hide my identity yeah yeah you
you're where you've got like uh you've
got like a a cast like a burning
do you remember when he breaks Leonardo
DiCaprio's arm we're gonna regret them
at some point right almost no matter
what you get you know right like it's
rare like imagine what you would have
gotten this was my joke it's like
imagine what you would have gotten at 16
that now you're like oh [ __ ] I don't
hate or like it is like I guarantee you
there's like thousands of people with
Kanye lyrics tattooed on their body yeah
I would love it if this if they were
even like nonsensical lyrics though you
know yeah they have the poop peep or the
the what was that song that he put out a
song to like troll people that was like
poopy something poops poop poop scoop
something like that somebody knows one
of these people out here knows how many
people are watching this I don't know
usually I get like a thousand views it's
[ __ ] overall well a thousand overall
gotcha but right now probably like 30 or
40. the chat's moving I'm impressed
yeah I mean uh there's like three or
four people out of every 40. that chat
yeah they're doing their own thing
they're going off on Tony H they're
doing like a running gag about who's
Tony Tony Hawk exactly yeah I just saw
Tony Hawkins I don't know but I was told
not to look at the comments so I won't
but like I mean yeah I think that uh
uh like imagine if your body looked like
your Trapper Keeper or your five-star
notebook did
dude you remember people would go like
they'd go to summer and they'd be like
hip-hop kids and they'd come back with
like slip knot and ball chain [ __ ]
necklaces and like that your whole
identity would change over a summer you
know and like yeah you're by the time
you get a tattoo you're old enough to
get a tattoo I don't even think you're
smart enough to like get the right thing
you know yeah well wait how old do you
have to be to get a tattoo like 18 is
that is that a law I mean I think
there's you can certainly get tattoos
before them but I think most places at
least without like I think some places
you could have like a parent by the way
if you're a parent taking your kid in to
get a tattoo at 14 you're probably not
doing great as a parent that's why but
I'm sure like a tribal leader sure but
even that that's like a tattoo that you
actually probably won't regret where
like I mean if I would have gotten a
like a Sublime tattoo I'd have to commit
suicide now you know well I think it's
the problem with our culture that we
don't have anything like concrete or
long lasting like Jesus is like no one's
religious anymore there's nothing like
to latch onto like the American flag
maybe I love I love it's a fake fort in
this town and they got imagine if you
got 1914. I love that Hans is like he's
like a socialist Christian conservative
it's like Economic Policy the most
liberal you can be and he's like we need
everyone to have kids and go to church
or your pieces of [ __ ] yeah we need to
come I genuinely like that because I
think like people get just like they're
on one team now well I don't want to say
I'm a concussion no you are I'm telling
I'm saying it I'm not just Asian
uh it's also black pink for the record
but anyway it's black pink I think very
pro-woman
that's a breast cancer awareness band
right right but uh forgive the ignorant
I know you were born in New Jersey right
and then you started comedy in Seattle
you now reside in Austin like is it when
you say that you're South Korean like
your parents are first generation
immigrants from South Korea I see so
yeah
ethnically genetically how old were they
when they came to the states like 22.
okay and then how old were they when
they had you 23. oh my God damn yeah do
you speak Korean yeah nice it's my first
language is it yeah have you ever been
back I mean I'm not going to speak
English to my parents that have been in
America for two years yeah well you were
probably not speaking very well at the
point when they'd been here for two
years right you were uh one do you have
a kid you were one year old
when the kids started talking around one
but you so they were like oh that's so
interesting I never because how well did
they know English when they moved here
like uh Korean that's been in America a
year so they didn't start learning
English till they came here they knew
like basic things I actually don't know
I was too young to have a conversation
how how old were you when you started
learning English
kindergarten right yeah yeah that's why
I knew it that's kind of the cycle I
used to work for an immigration attorney
a lot of like second generation because
they're raised in the native language
it's not until they go off to school
that they start learning right damn so
yeah was that strange for you like it's
kindergarten and all of a sudden you're
kind of I mean you clearly were here in
English on TV and stuff right yeah I
mean but it's sort of like Asian to just
be like you can figure it out it'll be
hard but if you study yeah you'll get
there yeah it's so funny it's sort of
Asian to just to not speak Asian
language how much English do your
parents speak now they can talk you know
they they're out there living is it
they're in San Francisco which is San
Francisco's got a Chinatown like New
York I'm not saying your parents are
Chinese by the way I understand the
difference but whoa these two facts are
unrelated they're in Chinatown and San
Francisco and my parents are Korean but
in uh in in San Francisco when you get
to Chinatown it's like you're
transported to a different country yeah
and I think that that's like most places
even like when they have an Asian
District Seattle had an Asian District
yeah kick them all out yeah especially
in Tacoma well Tacoma's got an Asian
District but it's like three blocks why
did they kick them all out the Chinese
Exclusion Act they didn't want Chinese
they wanted this to be like a white area
Wow real Progressive Seattle I know dude
the the Puyallup Fair was an internment
camp yeah I'm not kidding it was like
Japanese yeah Japanese internment campus
yeah I mean uh I think San Francisco uh
was more welcoming to the Chinese yeah
well uh should we get ready for the show
yes I need to shower desperately very
stable well thank you we got a show
tonight A Summit City Comedy yeah at 7
30 and 9 30 if you're in Fort Wayne oh
if you're anywhere in the state of
Indiana drive to start driving now still
make the Late Show yeah and hang out
with these brothers tonight [ __ ] I'm
still speaking of laptop
these brothers okay you're gonna do the
[ __ ] found out who on this podcast is
autistic okay